good bad or indifferent Reservoir Dogs
didn't really exist before I did it
there's a whole story about this Hong
Kong movie City on fire if you've ever
seen City on fire it's very very
different from my movie the section that
they say I took I did take from it all
right absolutely I took from it but it's
a very different movie they actually
talked to the director Ringo lamb and
goes wow Tarantino took the last 10
minutes of my movie made an entire movie
about it well that's a [ __ ] different
movie that's very very different but the
point being though is what I had to say
and my kind of idea of crime films and
my idea of dialogue you know there was
Barry Levinson and Tin Men and there was
good Fellas and there was all kinds
there's the David Mamet stuff all that
stuff existed that was sort of like
Reservoir Dogs but it wasn't Reservoir
Dogs it didn't have this aesthetic that
I'd been having it was a scene it was a
mood for only a little bit or a section
of the movie but it was never the whole
enchilada